on December 13th U.S prosecutors charged
FTX founder Sam bankman freed with eight
counts of Fraud and conspiracy I think
it's fair to say that by any anyone's
life this is one of the biggest
Financial frauds in American history the
charges were announced amid a series of
events playing out across two countries
that also included an arrest in the
Bahamas a criminal indictment and a
congressional hearing on the crypto
exchange's sudden demise
Bahamian police said they took bankman
freed into custody at his apartment in
Nassau on December 12 for charges of
various Financial offenses against laws
of the United States which are also
offenses against laws of the
Commonwealth of the Bahamas authorities
said the arrest was made based on an
indictment filed by the U.S attorney's
office for the southern district of New
York Bateman freed and his
co-conspirator stole billions of dollars
from FTX customers the indictment
accuses bankman freed of
misappropriating ftx.com customers
deposits and using those to pay expenses
and debts of Alameda research his crypto
hedge fund
since FTX filed for bankruptcy in
November bank mcfried has said in
multiple interviews that he bore
responsibility for the company's
collapse but he did not knowingly commit
any fraud I was trying to do the best I
could obviously that wasn't nearly as
good as I thought it was bankman freed
is reviewing the charges with his legal
team and considering all of his legal
options his lawyer said
also on December 13th the Securities and
Exchange Commission alleged in a civil
lawsuit that bankman free diverted
customer funds from the start of FTX to
support Alameda the SEC says that while
he spent lavishly on office space and
condominiums in the Bahamas and sank
billions of dollars of customer funds
into speculative Venture Investments
bankman Freed's House of Cards began to
crumble his Brazen multi-year scheme
finally came to an end when FTX Alameda
and their Tangled webbed of Affiliates
file for bankruptcy on November 11 2022.
that collapse has had far-reaching
consequences for FTX customers for its
investors and for its counterparties the
commodity Futures Trading commission
another U.S markets regulator filed a
separate lawsuit on the same day linking
his alleged fraudulent conduct at
Alameda and FTX to markets that the cftc
regulates
the complaint to the latest twist and a
saga that has rattled the world of
cryptocurrencies and has caught the
attention of U.S lawmakers
rest assured that this committee will
not stop until we uncover the full truth
behind the collapse of FTX at a
congressional Hearing in Washington
ftx's new chief executive told lawmakers
that the company has incurred losses in
excess of seven billion dollars
this isn't this isn't uh uh you know
sophisticated whatsoever this is just
plain old embezzlement hours after the
criminal indictment was unsealed a
Magistrate Judge in the Bahamas denied
bail to bankman Freed and said he should
be remanded to Bahamian custody until
February 8 2023